hello my name is Alistair Bruce and I'm
here to answer your questions about the
coronation here at Westminster Abbey
[Music]
Jim that's a good question because of
course the king became king in real
terms on the moment the heartbeat of the
late Queen ended
but that's according to statute and our
constitutional settlement requires
certain processes to be met and the
inauguration of the head of state of
this Kingdom has always involved a
coronation at its conclusion and in a
way the end of one Reign comes with
sadness and the start of a new reign
culminates in the joy of a coronation so
you're right that constitutionally there
is no real difference between the king
before he comes here to Westminster
as to when he leaves but the coronation
is a tradition and it is part of the way
in the United Kingdom we do things
the anointing is the most sacred part of
the coronation service and traditionally
they brought a canopy Over The Sovereign
like a sort of tent
but the intention on this occasion is to
put a canopy around the king and it's
partly
to make it easier for him to remove the
items of clothing that he will need to
do in order to be anointed and I think
in this day and age it is a courtesy to
him that that should be private and this
seems to be a sensible way in order to
preserve that privacy
foreign at the moment of Coronation the
king will be crowned with this crime
sent Edward's crime which is the
coronation crime of the United Kingdom
actually at the moment he isn't depicted
with a crown on the stamps but where you
do see one shown artistically that is an
heraldic crime which looks very similar
and looks like this
when the king leaves The Abbey at the
end of his coronation he will change and
wear the Imperial stake crime that's
this one and this is the one that
perhaps has most of the historically
famous stones in it that tell the story
of the United Kingdom
when Queen Camilla is crowned she's
crowned as Queen consort that is the
consort or wife of the king so her
crowning has no effect on her children
they will never be in the line of
succession the only people who can be in
the line of succession are the people in
the bloodline that goes right back
through history to people like William
the Conqueror
the coronation looks much smaller than
it has historically but then coronations
have always changed and they reflect
what's going on in the country at the
time and I dare say the king taking
advice has taken the view that a smaller
coronation much more slimmed down makes
sense for the state of the United
Kingdom at the moment where we are in
history and the attitudes everybody has
in the past they built a huge Annex out
here particularly in 1953 for vast
coronations of members of the House of
Lords wearing velvet robes all of that
is not going to take place it will be a
very simple service that meets all the
historical traditions and yet takes us
through the last final point of
inaugurating a new head of state
Gina you're right Queen Victoria's
coronation invitation did describe her
as Her Sacred Majesty it was also sacred
for her Uncle William IV but from Edward
VII onwards it's just been playing his
or her majesty and I think that reflects
the fact that times change but a central
part to the coronation ceremony is the
sacrament the Christian sacrament of
anointing and I think that that is why
people referred to Majesty as very often
sacred but we live in different times
and I think it's appropriate not to
refer to Charles III as his sacred
Majesty in 2023
foreign
it's very difficult to say where the
best place to be is for the coronation
but they have now shown the route that
the king's Carriage will take both out
and the Grove State coach will take back
and it's basically from Buckingham
Palace here to The Abbey along the mall
and then coming down Whitehall
anywhere along that route would be ideal
if you want to watch the whole
procession pass by but I think the very
best place to see it will be on Sky News
because we'll take you inside the Abbey
we'll take you to see all the events as
they take place but if you want to be on
your location near Buckingham Palace
have your mobile phone ready join us and
we'll try and take you through the story
foreign
[Music]